eat the toilet paper so it wipes on the
way
out good evening everyone my name is
pewdiepie
and i don't mean to brag but i have a
very large brain
just like the person who wrote this
god-awful
reddit post so today we're going to
explore
more people with big brains and perhaps
you might find that you are a big brain
as well i love this one
you don't have a skeleton inside you
you're a brain
you are inside a skeleton you're
piloting a bone mech
that is using meat armor i never felt
more powerful
i mean technically you're not wrong big
brain very large
brain i bet this guy can whip out a
cobblestone generator in half a second
my god so we're all an anime mech cat
that's so
cool to be honest it's not premarital
sex
if you never get married
what i've been lied to
a new scientific study claims that
fertility
is hereditary if your parents didn't
have any children chances are
you won't either it took me a second but
big brain that's
i understand this isn't minecraft
it's funny how we we tend to mimic our
parents behavior
what you never okay i got one for you
guys
here's one for you big brains what
smells better
than it tastes
a nose i get it
i was like what does a nose smell like
oh
you can't spell advertisements
without semen between the tits
nine-year-olds write that down things i
wish
i didn't know okay this is not big brain
get out of my sight
so i met a cute guy at the bar last
night danced with him says he doesn't
have a girlfriend we exchange snapchat
look him up on facebook and he doesn't
have a girlfriend
he has a wife big brain
everyone knows the smartest people in
the world
socrates stephen hawkins einstein they
all had very
large heads einstein's brain weighed
only
which is less than average adult male
einstein had
small brain small brains
here's one for you youtube lovers what's
the best way to download a youtube video
screenshot each second and play it on
powerpoint
small break hey if a public bathroom
door
is locked don't forget to try and
repeatedly open it
and give the person using it and
paralyzing
anxiety it's like uh when you're waiting
for the elevator
and the the button is clearly lit up but
someone comes in anyway
and decides to click it for you the door
is locked stop trying to open it
i'm having a [ __ ] cutting your tennis
balls in half
allows you to store two more balls in
each can
thus saving space small brain very small
my brain is so tiny this is another
typical
problem with capitalist america why
can't they just they can clearly fit
more tennis ball
but they chose not to disgusting people
will stop showing you pictures of their
kids if
you whisper oh frick yeah under your
breath
when you look at their photos
ah wow what a fantastic tip that
that is so helpful ah heck yeah
oh i like that one
what the hell only a fool would buy ikea
furniture
instead just download the instructions
and keep emailing their service
department to say
that i'm missing a piece until they ship
me all the pieces
over a six months period swedish spray
this is an old hack everyone is sweet
and dust this
come on don't waste my time being vegan
has
been so freaking easy i literally just
stare at the sun
and i'm full thanks photosynthesis i
mean i never tried it so
maybe it works
if you are behind someone at an atm late
at night
let them know that you're not a threat
by giving them a gentle kiss on their
neck
see this is the kind of stuff that i
wish people taught me when i was growing
up
it takes 45 muscles to frown but only 10
muscles to smile
frown all day lose weight get ripped
gains
[Music]
yeah bro have you been working now yeah
right now
i actually feel it damn i will actually
get a big break
my forehead will be massive
the games apply garlic
to freshly open cut or burn to
immediately
intensify the paint thank you
this is so helpful oh god i've been
barely injured
garlic please what does that help okay
here you go
i keep a fruit sticker on top of my head
so that if cannibals ever eat me
he'll have to peel the sticker off first
giving me
time to escape shaq what's wrong with
you
how to learn anything 10 times faster
i speed at the video times 1.5
so that i can learn 15 times faster
[Music]
damn oh i'm sorry you read books
i listen to audiobooks at 10 times the
speed
oh i'm sorry you listen 10 times to
speed i listen that five audio books at
the same time
in 20 times the speed it's quick it's
easy and it's free
pouring river water into your socks why
would i do that
lmi it's quick it's easy it's free
[Music]
you can apply that to anything literally
buying pewdiepie merch
it's quick it's easy it's
you get the point if you ever feel alone
watch a horror movie late at night with
the lights off
you won't feel so alone anymore thanks
satan you're the best
when the baby on board sticker is a
little
faded and beat up you know the kid is at
least
a year or two old now and the car is
safe to ram
think i'll remember that one i think i
keep that one in the memory bank thank
you very much
poke your finger in someone's mouth
while they are yawning
to establish dominance big brain
wait my mindset was visited to me oh
i've seen this one i got a girl pregnant
in high school
so i told my parents i was getting
bullied and we
moved modern problems
require modern solutions that is awful
by the way just so we're just so quickly
that is not big brain that is despicable
brain
same thing actually fighting tip pro
fighting tip
sneeze on your knuckles before a fight
in order to inflict poison damage
damn big brain
very big very large brain
oh here's a good one if you touch your
pp while you watch you can
pretend like you're having
oh oh that took me a long time
okay
oh my god take a little weight off your
checked luggage that is actually a big
brain
i like that we can't do that in uh i
think european airports
they keep them like dang it
how to get over your fear of the dark as
soon as you turn the lights
off starts touching pee pee poo pooing
no monster wants to see that while doing
it
stare at the corner and whisper
tenderly this is for you
i always thought about like in a horror
movie if someone just does something
really crazy
to throw the monster off but i think
this one takes the price that's
extremely large brain not even i would
think of that mr
president jesus well that explains it
if you count their wine snubs confuse
them by using this move
oh my god life hack
possums say you can show yourself now
every time you're about to leave
an apparently empty room someday there
might actually be someone there
and they will be really impressed
i've been doing this for 29 years so far
no nothing happened
very large brain now if you have the
biggest brain of them all
you will be checking out represent.com
slash pewdiepie merch
it is epically big brain we don't have
any big brain merch though
sven's cool thanks for watching gamers
smash like if you enjoyed subscribe
and remember to just take like life
big brain my brain is so big i don't
know how to speak how do i make it outro
big break what you never play two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]
swedish prey